[Music]
hey
what's up oh no you did it again yeah
had the volume
on yeah we're in the chats talking about
nuts
[Laughter]
so it's uh we're gonna do this uh review
of this uh first of all [ __ ] sick as
a dog
my nose feels like i'm smelling like a
rotten forest fire
made out of plastic plastic
plastic rotten foreign got that no
nose infection i wasn't coughing last
night though so
yeah i think you slept all night i
didn't cough all night either yeah
i don't i think i have the same thing
but i don't the only thing that bothered
me last night was i woke up a couple
times and like my face was real hot
like i felt like i had a fever i had
that a couple days ago yeah yeah
but um i you know i was able to go on my
walk this morning and everything like
that without feeling too shitty
sweating bullets in a [ __ ] cold sweat
no yeah i
did that for a while no i just it was
weird like the rest of me wasn't hot
just my face
yeah okay but um i could we have like
this big bag of cough drops just off
screen
and i had a bunch of cough drops off
screen cough drop well
i'll scream cop and we had like um
little piles of them on
on each side of the you know on the on
the bed but i didn't wake up
coughing all right we watched this movie
last night it was a [ __ ] trip what
was it called
wolf house the wolf house the wolf house
they just added this on shutter although
i think it might be from 2018 if i'm not
mistaken it's a visual experience man
this is one of the weirdest things i've
ever seen and that's saying something
stop motion movie where the cameras i
guess it's in the live is
i guess it's in a full-size house i
guess it is yeah i looked it up it is a
it's actually i don't think it's a house
i think it's a museum that they let them
use this [ __ ] took
five years to make which
if you watch it i believe it the whole
thing is taking place as paintings on
the walls
moving and they're the paintings are
moving
and then things come out of the wall 3d
figures made out of looks like masking
tape and they move
and their eyes blank and it's narrated
in
spanish and in german at certain times
this crazy ass [ __ ] tale about this
chick who
took two pigs and turned them into
children and
over time they they caught on fire and
then she had to heal them up and then
then they wanted to eat her eventually
this [ __ ] was ridiculous
creepy ass [ __ ]
yeah i mean this is like i said this is
a very very experimental
film um it's more of a visual experience
than anything else
it's i guess it's kind of like a fable
or like a fairy tale
now what i did find out yeah so the
story is
it's weird because at the very beginning
i don't remember if you saw this because
maybe you were
in the bathroom or something but at the
very beginning
there's like a little it almost kind of
looks like one of those old like
propaganda short films you know i mean
like from the 50s or 60s or whatever
um and it was a few minutes and there
was somebody on there talking about
um this colony and
you know we lived by the land and they
had like
magical i don't think they said magical
honey but they had
you know all this organ and everything
was awesome and
there were all these quote unquote
rumors about them and blah blah blah
so that's kind of like the framing
device and then they're like so
we're presenting that this film that we
found
you know and then they start showing the
stop-motion animation part
now this was uh chilean i think the two
guys that made it the animators were
chilean
now this it kind of has aspects of
little red riding hood
but i'm like watching it i'm like this
has to be referring to something
particularly especially because of
you know the film at the beginning
because they were setting it up and some
of the things that they said in there
the fact that it's in spanish and in
german
and i was like i gotta figure out what
this this has to be based on something
or that has to be based on something and
so
what it ends up being based on
is that and i had actually never heard
of this
like i knew like some general
information about this but i had never
heard of this particular thing
the colony that they're talking about is
actually called
dignity colony yeah yeah yeah that's
yeah yeah yeah and there's like so
joseph mengele was there um
no well that's what that's what
wikipedia said yeah not true
um but they so the guy that is quote
unquote the wolf
in this because you hear his voice
sometimes like speaking
german um that's supposed to be based on
uh i think the guy's name is um schaefer
paul schaefer or something like that
yeah yeah
he was the one that was doing those
weird experiments on kids yeah so there
was like all kinds of you do a show on
this on this [ __ ]
yeah okay growing up in brazil there's a
place a lot like this
people don't realize that south america
real south america
the south of the south of brazil
uruguay paraguay chile
and argentina are very germanic there's
also a lot of irish immigration
immigration going on there i go there i
fit right in
all right a lot of people just thought i
was brazilian
um you're gonna bunch of irish last
names and they've been going there since
the 20s
you know this wasn't just the reason why
the nazis ran there after the war
is because there was german and your
european
immigration into south america going all
the way back 1700s even
you know so you can go there and blend
in
um but paul schaefer was a [ __ ] freak
we gotta talk about that
even though schaefer i thought was in um
argentina
no was that chile uh yeah and actually
i'm pretty sure it was yeah he fled to
chile
and then he he was the founder of
dignity colony yeah
community dignidad i think is what it
was called in spanish i forgot but
yeah that was in the 60s like early 60s
yeah and he was
doing there like all the well he was a
child molester he
you know and he like fled to fled from
german christian
community that was like a cult that had
elements of kind of ex-nazis in it
he was doing weird hormonal experiments
on their children to keep them from
going into puberty
to somehow prevent them from having to
deal with original sin or something
um south american governments found out
out about this and instead stopping him
hired him
as a [ __ ] kind of like a secret
torture camp
to help them disappear
certain political um enemies that
regimes had
yeah so this goes back to some of these
other things that i told
we told you in other shows a lot of
times these cults don't get dissolved
they get absorbed by intelligence
agencies
because they just use they use them
they're like oh okay we can send you for
prison for what you're doing here but if
you help us
we'll [ __ ] protect you here torture
these people for us and tell us what you
find
they do that kind of [ __ ] yeah and that
way
it's all deniable it's [ __ ] child
island
[ __ ] but yeah that's what um
so that's basically what the background
of this movie is although i guess if you
didn't know a lot about that
yeah it's kind of making sense now you
wouldn't really yeah
you know you can just watch it for the
artistry
and as i said it's it's a little bit
like a fairy tale in the sense i mean
because the story of it
is there's a girl named maria there once
was a girl named maria
and um and uh she
flees from this colony and she runs out
because she gets in trouble because she
stole some pigs or
she wasn't working or something like
that i can't remember what it was and
she flees into the woods and she finds
this house
the wolf house and she goes in there and
stays in there now she has
there's a couple of pigs in this house
and
over time she starts turning them into
humans
like they slowly start turning into
humans and she makes them clothes
and then she gives them some of this
magical honey from the colony and it
like gives them blonde hair and um
all this other kind of stuff so
so so i kind of feel like more sense now
yeah yeah yeah
that's what i meant i was like because
i'm watching it and i was like i know
that there has to be and i kind of got
i was like this has to has have
something to do with the nazis that fled
to south america no
i got that but i wasn't sure yeah now
now you're saying i didn't realize that
i didn't have it in a south american
context yeah
i thought it was something from spain
mm-hmm but um
the the um i think i've told you another
other show i think i told the audience
in other shows when i was
growing up in brazil and [ __ ] at
school of brother to sao paulo
some of the americans
i say that quote some of the americans
that were there
came out of these communities that we're
talking about but that's not just commun
community
dignity community there's ones in brazil
um there's a state brazil there's a
place in brazil called
gramadu and gramato is german all right
and a lot of them went there and
uh you could
some of these people that were wanted
could kind of like erase their
identities
and then give their children's new
identities
like brazilian identities uruguayan
identities paraguayan
chilean and then eventually they would
morph into american identities
remember i told you to go to favela with
dude and [ __ ] would
see real nazis in the favela selling
weed yeah
yeah well he was an american but you
could trace it back to part of that
regime that rent that ran
back or that ran away but then they came
to the united states now and all that
had to do with
operation paper clip too the us was also
involved
not only did they launder money and [ __ ]
they were laundering people
it's amazing man the world is a lot more
complicated than you think it is
but uh that's always the case yeah but
you were talking about
um uh what's his name [ __ ] mangala
all right during the time that i was
there as a kid my mother was
was secretary of the consul general of
brazil all right my mother's state
department
she's state department she's also ex-dea
and there's been some requests that for
me to have her on the show
recently uh i'll get into that maybe
like on a wednesday
that's kind of a [ __ ] difficult
subject and every i'm
i'm an only child and both my parents
have been diagnosed with cancer and
you know i got a lot of responsibility
to take care of people you know
i'll get into that on another show
anyway would be good to have her
talk about when she saw the poultry guys
with us and uh
maybe some of the weird [ __ ] that she
saw in south america but anyway um
was his name mangala she was on duty
when they found mangala's body
yeah yeah he died at uber on ubetuba
beach
in uh brazil i think it was in the 70s
actually
but he had been buried and then they
they found his body later
and they tried to trace where he came
from and
that i don't i think he was in brazil
the whole time so this thing about him
coming through
community dignity community i doubt it i
think he stayed in brazil
and here's another weird thing um that a
lot of people don't know
mangala got married in brazil and he
married a black woman
okay so all this looking master race
[ __ ] that i'll tell that that was all
kind of like they didn't really believe
in that [ __ ] they just did what they
were told to do
he married a black woman after that and
um
it was there then i think he has kids
but
they probably i wasn't told anything
about him you know i mean like i didn't
have the security clearances i was
just a dependent i was hearing about all
that happening yeah
but my mother saw his skull yeah because
they had
fragments of his skull and they were
trying to figure it out you know other
people you know
instead we're looking at it israel
wasn't stuff was involved
they wanted the body there was brazil
was involved in it too it was just it
was a weird time
um yeah anyway
i'm going down another path anyway the
the whole
[ __ ]
western europeans and in deep parts of
the south america
south america if you go down south
enough it becomes another honky
motherland
yeah basically scott says isn't paul
shaffer the dude who played keyboards
for let him
yeah he did he was although although the
the schaffer we're talking about it's
um his last name only has one f
and it has an umlaut
that's what i was thinking too i was
like wait is there all shape for that so
yeah i forgot
no i was a creepy old dude yeah
nazi-like kind of guy he wasn't a nazi
though i don't think
it's just uh he was working with with
runaway nazis yeah yeah and like i said
he
he left germany because of child
molestation charges
yeah he fled he ended up being given
safe harbor
to people that were running from the
regime or running from
you know what i mean um what you call uh
nazi hunters and stuff he was
and and south american governments it
wasn't just one it was a bunch of them
were protecting them
um they were valuable to them those they
had their own versions of operation
paper clip
but yeah so yeah so when so i think that
the wolf character in this
um that's presumably who um
paul shaffer is presumably who the wolf
character is based on
and the colony that they're talking
about is this colony that was in chile
so like i said i was watching it and i
said that this has to do
has to have something to do with like
the escape nazis that went to south
america but that was
what i got from it but i didn't know all
the exact details so now
now it makes a lot more sense now like i
said if you don't know any of that
you can still watch it as just like an
artistic and a visual experience because
it is
amazing and a lot of the um
the imagery is really really creepy it's
really kind of like
another thing that's really creepy about
it too is the sound design
yeah because i like the way they left in
i don't know if they added this later or
whatever i mean i'm probably sure they
did but
like when the um like when the figures
are
forming themselves and like i said it's
largely i don't know it looks like some
some of it looks like tape and some like
masking tape of different colors and
some of it looks like some other things
like paper mache or something like that
like when it's forming itself
it makes like this kind of like
like noise in the background and it's
like really really creepy
and then kind of the voices are kind of
creepy because like the maria voice like
the oh
the um the voice over she's always
talking like really quietly
and then you have like the guy that's
the that's the wolf's voice
he's always kind of like creepy and
everything but yeah so she has these
pigs and she turns them into essentially
children
and then as it goes on like i said it
she gives them this honey and it gives
them blonde hair and blue eyes
and then as it goes on they
decide well she decides that we're
running out of food in the house
and so i have to go out and get some and
then the kids are like
um no you can't because the wolf is out
there and he'll get you
we have plenty of food here you can stay
here
and then it turns out the kids want to
eat her so
then she's trying to call the wolf to
come and eat the kids before they can
eat her
so you know what i mean so the it's
like i said it's very much in the vein
of if
this colony which like i said a
fictionalized version
of dignity colony had made a really
weird
david lynchian stop-motion animation
propaganda film yeah this would have
been what it was like
you know what i mean it's it reminded me
a lot of
if you guys remember like i guess from
the 90s i guess it was
um what was that show that was on mtv
liquid television
and it had like all different shorts of
like different animation like different
animation styles and stuff
it reminded me of something you would
see on there
you know what i mean yeah but we could
not believe like the whole time now this
isn't
it this is almost a feature-length movie
it's 73 minutes um
so it's you know it is a time commitment
for
something that is this experimental okay
not gonna lie
for me after about 30 minutes i'd had
enough it should have been a lot slower
it should have been a lot faster and
shorter
i i thought it took too long yeah
it probably could have been a short film
yeah it's like the visual impact of it
started to wear off on me
and there didn't and i didn't i couldn't
really follow what the story was trying
to tell me
yeah so it started to become kind of
tedious
i was just saying yeah that's i liked it
though
yeah i'd have to see it again probably
you know if i had time
i was sitting there the whole time i was
thinking what the [ __ ] is this about
what would this be like on acid
and because i was telling like this is
probably one of the weirdest things i've
ever seen
but like i said we were watching a lot
of the time we were watching it we were
trying to figure out
how they did it like is this a doll
house or is it like a full size
and i was like it's got to be full size
because i'm like look they have like all
the furniture and there's clocks that
i've said
i felt like it would be a real pain to
try and get miniature everything
you know what i mean but then when i
found out and i was doing the um
the research for it later at least as
far as i can determine because i was
watching these four guys
who um i don't know where it was but
they owned some like uh
you know indie theaters and stuff and i
guess they had shown this like when it
first came out
and they were talking about it and they
said that it was a full
size it was like a house or it was a
museum that they let them
the guys use it's two guys um and they
let them use it for like
over a five-year period and like they
they didn't do it all at once obviously
because
like i said if you see it you'll
understand that this must have taken
taken just forever
because there's just always something
moving you know
it's just really really it's just really
cool the way like it'll go into a room
and then like the room like paints
itself like all around the side and then
like
a painting will paint itself on the wall
it'll become like 3d
and it's like and it's all done like
yeah and then and then like maria is
like painted on the wall and then she
comes out like 3d and then she's like
made out of tape
and all this other stuff and it's just
like this really really creepy
um i guess because it's because it's
handmade
and it looks it just looks really
unsettling
you know what i mean it's just it's not
polished it's not
real crude looking it's crude looking
but it's that that's what makes it cool
that's what makes
it like really really creepy looking and
like i said i think that the
the sound design is makes it real creepy
too because all that like skittering
kind of noise in the background like
with all the tape and everything
but yeah if you're into like
experimental stuff or stop motion
like check it out it does go you know
it's long
but um you know if you know the
background of it that it's
about dignity colony and stuff like that
you might like get more out of it i
guess
yeah we're gonna have to do a show about
some of that weird south american nazi
stuff
yeah we should actually you know what
i'm going to write it down right because
juan perez
otherwise was involved in all that kind
of stuff that's how they ended up
getting jet technology
um all kinds of weird stuff happened
over the decades
um another weird thing is that uh after
the american civil war
or the first one um general lee and a
lot of his staff officers and a lot of
the guys at the top of the confederacy
ran to brazil and uh there's a
town in brazil that's kind of like a
historical district it's protected
they're like
they protect them in the way we would
like protect native americans or
something
and it's these descendants of
confederates are there
and they speak english and with real
strong [ __ ]
accent southern accents and everything
and it's like
pre-war south you know and um
general lee's one of general lee's
descendants i think she's a
great-granddaughter
his name rita lee who's a famous uh
brazilian singer if you look at look up
brazilian singer rita lee
that is one of general lee's descendants
direct descendants
interesting yeah yeah so a lot of
a lot of the confederates and i think i
think what's his name was there too
um the president what's his name yeah um
the guy who was the president of the
confederacy what was his name
oh yeah well it was it was in davis
there you go
i was like i was like jim jefferson
davis i think jefferson
davis went there too either that or he
died right before he left or something
like that
i'd have to i'd have to go back in there
yeah but
um they uh
south america is a trip it's a trip and
um
interesting yeah but uh the german town
in uh brazil called gramato i went there
and it was like going to germany
and when i spoke english they [ __ ]
snarled at me
yeah they asked if i was german and i
said no i'm american
snarled in german at the old lady did
and turned her back on and walked off
well yeah it's like [ __ ] you get out of
here
straight up [ __ ] german national
socialists
from the war and you know she was the
right age and everything at that time
that was back in the 80s
cranky but then a little damn
gingerbread looking houses and [ __ ]
everywhere
yeah yeah so now
it i'm glad that i looked um look some
of this [ __ ] up because i was so
intrigued by the movie that i was kind
of like
that i knew it had to be based on
something like that or based on
something specific
and i think that now that i looked all
that stuff up
um i have like even a greater
appreciation for the movie because i can
see where they're coming from they've
essentially made a fairy tale
out of it you know what i mean like out
of this colony that was there that
was kind of like like you said it was
kind of like a cult where they all kind
of stayed and so
so the main character she has escaped
from this cult for a little while but
then
i guess the point of it was that she ran
away for a little while but then like
she
she went back into she asked like the
dude that was running it like to come
save her or whatever
graham's funny because i said i'll never
forget all what to do
how do i come up with this i never
forget
what's his name
man we could be rich off all these damn
t-shirts right if i if only i had time
to make them all you can't make them all
yeah
[Laughter]
for some reason country yeah for some
reason that just reminded me i don't
know if you guys have seen
um rock and roll that uh that canadian
uh post-apocalyptic animated film
which is actually i really really love
that movie i can't i still
want to review it one of these days but
um i think there was one point where
mock was like oh my dear what's her face
and that's kind of what it reminded me
of just that
hey i can picture it in my mind i just
can't remember the name you know what
i'm talking about
well i was sitting there going i was
like it starts with the j it starts the
j it starts to the j and then like you
came
up with it yeah oh jefferson
well gosh man we've already been on for
33. okay all right let me let me let me
let me throw another [ __ ] aspect at
you
all right he's going to throw an aspect
at me
in mountain poultry guys when i had the
[ __ ] out of body experience the dude
that i was in the in the um
in the uh in the barracks with who
threatened to beat my ass because he saw
the [ __ ]
obe happened so don't ever tell anybody
about that yet
his name was jeff davis all right really
he was named after jefferson davis
well there you go yeah they're funny
jefferson
his dad named jefferson davis
[Laughter]
he's from georgia yeah i think you think
it was george no north carolina no
no north north or south carolina one of
the two
one of them caroline one of the
carolinas that's where he's from
victor says where is this movie
streaming which one rock and roll or
this one i'm talking about the wolf
house is on
shutter yeah rock and roll i don't know
where that one is i
i feel like i had it um
i saw it on cable a lot back in the 80s
and i taped it
so i had a you know old vhs of it
but lately i don't know it seems it's
it fell into obscurity which is kind of
a shame yeah because it had a [ __ ]
kick-ass soundtrack man there were a lot
of good animated ones
iggy pop was on lou reed and blondie and
cheap drake and stuff
that weird french one about the damn
aliens that were keeping humans as pets
yeah remember that one what was that
weird one with the cats
fella day philadelphia that was german
that was german
i think it was called fantastic world
was the french one i was thinking of it
really weird um there was another one
that was kind of like
it was kind of like a dungeons and
dragons animated movie about [ __ ]
it's in the 70s about you know
wizards and [ __ ] gigantic spiders and
[ __ ] it wasn't it wasn't um
it wasn't like lord of the rings no it
wasn't lord of the rings there was
another one this guy was think was
british
oh okay well lord of the rings is
british but it was uh i think it was a
i don't know it's a long time i don't
know well they remember seeing posters
of it when i was a kid there was so much
like sword and sorcery stuff like back
in the day they were smoking so much
weed taking mushrooms and [ __ ]
in the 70s you know
but i remember like ralph's back says
fantastic planet
yeah yeah yeah that was a weird i
thought it was a kid i think i've seen
that one
yeah i may i may well have yeah
i think i was talking the other day
about that weird ass
jack and the beanstalk cartoon that i
didn't realize was japanese because it'd
been dubbed into english when i saw it
when i was like 11 or 12 years old
and uh and i loved it and it was like
it's so weird like with the little
mechanical witch and everything but i
didn't realize that it was japanese
because i didn't know what [ __ ]
yeah anime was back then i'm gonna have
to get off the stream man my nose is
killing me
oh his nose i'm tired okay let's go
all right so we will be back tomorrow
talking about another new movie
hopefully tom will feel better
no i'll probably feel worse oh
it's all gonna get worse yeah that's the
spirit
yeah all right so oh [ __ ] all right so
uh oh good save good save he almost
knocked his coffee cup over
yeah all right uh we will see you guys
tomorrow we'll talk about another movie
thanks everybody for dropping by
bye